[Music]
we got this one call here from san
antonio
from jan it says
my son just revealed that his wife
confessed to a six-month long affair
with a co-worker
our family is understandably angry at
his wife but my son wants to work
through forgiveness and reconciliation
my question is how do we navigate this
as a family
showing love and forgiveness yet working
through the complete lack of trust we
all have for her and the hurt we feel
oh great great question this reminds me
of my friend
i think it's jennifer she's
like she is one of the best
most wonderful people on the planet
and what makes her awesome is there's
been once a few times that she said hey
i met somebody
but i think you've talked about them are
we friends with him
and i love the way she asked that like
i'll burn their house down if we need to
but i kind of like them so if it's cool
like and so
i
have friends like like that i'm so right
or die with that are if you hurt my
friends if you hurt my family members
man it's hard for me it's hard i have a
loyalty issue pathologically so
and
when it comes to imagining somebody
cheating on like you know on my kid
the amount of hurt that would cause the
amount of devastation that all that
would just be so hard
and then my son turns and says or my
daughter turns and says
i'm gonna work through this
i've forgiven her i'm asking you to
forgive her um i'm gonna have her a part
of my life and if y'all want to be a
part of my life
she's she she's we're a package deal
so here's a couple of things um that i
would think through here number one
never ever ever ever talk bad about his
wife
two reasons number one you never know as
much as you think you know your son you
you as parents never know what's going
on behind closed doors same thing goes
with friends
like my friend you never know what's
going on behind closed doors
not that there's ever an excuse to have
a six month long affair but i'm just
saying you never know what's going on
behind closed doors there's always
another side to a story
so that's why number one you don't talk
bad number two is if you come out of the
gate i can't believe she did this she's
a this she's a that oh my whatever
and then they get married or they stay
married and then she becomes the mother
of your grandkids
those words will always ring in her head
those words will always ring in your
son's head
so don't
don't talk bad
ask your son how he's doing
know that she is probably struggling too
i'm gonna say tell you something crazy
reach out and see how she's doing
because it looks like she is gonna be
bathed in shame and guilt
and heartbreak
and all the mess that comes with this
so reach out to both of them and see if
they're doing okay
let her know if she needs anything
you'll be there
you'll respond and i know you forget
that dude if anyone hurts my son what
i'm telling you is finding somebody new
to hate
never solves anything
forgiveness does
and i know that's hard
i know it's hard
so number one don't ever say anything
negative or bad
number two be very clear about your
boundaries
very clear whatever they happen to be
son if you get back with her
y'all will not be welcome in our home
that's your boundary be big boys and
girls and draw the boundary draw the
line
if you get back with him
i'm taking you out of the will i just
need you to know
that cool
if you go to that church i will not
support you if you
whatever it happens to be
if you're going to make your boundaries
make them clear
clear as kind say them out loud and hold
to them
the third thing here
is man
default to hospitality
invite him over
give her a hug
give him a hug
and then just turn the football game on
because as much as you want this to be
y'all's hurt your son's the one going
through this they're the one that have
to live with each other every day and
get up and go to bed and get up and go
to bed and make this thing
work to excavate everything and build
something else that's new
get along get on with forgiveness and
reconciliation this is their journey
what they need is people to anchor in
and love them and support them
and
not to be judgmental be like i saw her
on her phone do you know what that don't
do that don't do that
hug them both when they come in if he
says she's back then she's back
or unless that violates one of your
boundaries
and the meta here is
ah man
freaking facebook took meta
from me i gotta come up with another
word
unbelievable
the big overarching balloon umbrella
thing
let me know what to call it ben that's
your job come up with a new meta word i
don't know what it is but i'll think of
something
[Laughter]
is default to forgiveness default to
hospitality
man
default to hugs first and i know that
makes me sound cliche and lame and
cheesy but it's right